We are low income. We are not wealthy by any means,
and yet I am still able to be home full time.
Now, it hasn't always been like that.
I watched kids the first couple years of our marriage in our own home.
So I understand when people actually say they can't make it work.
That being said,
I do believe more people could stay home than they think they can.
America is overrun by consumerism.
You have to have the next.
But if people truly evaluated their finances,
cut back on the extra luxuries in life,
I swear, more people would be able to stay home.
I get it. People don't wanna give up their vacation times.
They don't wanna give up all the fun things
they get to do with their lives
when you have more money. But it's really about priority over privilege.
I'm prioritizing our home because that is what is important to me.
I am prioritizing being with my child full time
because that is what is very important to me.
As the saying goes, if there's a will,
there's a way.
And we make the sacrifices necessary to make this lifestyle possible.